[Music]
hi everyone thanks for coming especially
9 a.m. after a concert how many of you
made it out last night to the
chainsmokers
oh wow a lot of you anger here so well
done to you my name is Stephen Buchi I
lead our higher education team at Google
and this session is on disaster recovery
and storage and we've got some great
universities here that will be speaking
but I'm sure you probably all remember
the news from about a year ago that with
hurricane Harvey and that we happen to
have a school district that reached out
to us and said we learned a hard lesson
your disaster recovery site should not
be located just 30 minutes from your
main data center because that may also
be affected and make reached out and say
we're having some problems if you could
really help us out and the good news is
with Google cloud platform in G suite we
were able to step in and help them
recover from this but I think the what
we want to talk about as we hopefully
today is helping you avoid what happened
with hurricane Harvey and making sure
that you're thinking through your
strategy so as you hear from these three
universities you'll hear out a little
bit of the first two buckets so I wanted
to call this out because there are
different types of storage
the first being G suite this we offer
for free to many institutions that are
educational in fact all of them they're
not for profit and so that has really
around file storage as you think about
backup and recovery so things like
essays and manuals and presentations
collaborative Docs so you'll hear from
Steve from University of Minnesota about
how they are using Google Drive for
backup and storage of those types of
materials the second bucket is around
Google cloud platform in our storage
classes so that is more object storage
so think about disaster recovery large
sets of genomics data etc we also have
other types of storage such as block
storage and structured data through
cloud sequel and I've put the link there
because there are so many to list that I
won't be able to go through them all but
if you want to check that out on the
website there's more details there so
when we think particularly around
disaster recovery and storage for Google
I think there's four key terms that we
are trying to design for trust secure
smart and
simple so if we go into that for example
with Google cloud platform one of the
things you have to do in order to trust
someone is make sure it there if you're
going to put your all of your files or
your your object storage into Google as
you trust this will actually be
available when you need it and so we
this is some data from Gartner looking
at the downtime of storage from the
different cloud providers and hopefully
we're recognizing that we will be there
when you need us in addition there are a
few other features that I think
differentiate when we're looking at
cloud storage options one is a single
consistent API so you have to manage
multiple api's and that API actually
works with other cloud providers as well
which makes it really easy to move data
edge caching given our network making
sure that the data can be easily brought
to you quickly consistency and things
around security like default encryption
that's automatically encrypt data at
rest in transit as well as object
lifecycle management so as you look at
for example our different buckets of
storage going from hot and
multi-regional all the way on the left
to cold which is really just archive we
can really easily help you move your
storage through that process
automatically through lifecycle
management the benefit of that to you is
that if you're not touching something
you can move it down in a class and
we'll save you some money so as we go
through this process and I'm not going
to read through all these different
buckets but just remember that we have
many different scenarios and different
options to match what you need for
disaster recovery so as we go from there
I'm going to introduce three of our
speakers will have arun from stanford
who will be talking about how they're
using Google cloud platform for their
disaster recovery Steve from University
of Minnesota who will be talking about
how they're using G suite for a lot of
their file backup and Joshua from
Georgia State also talking about how
they're using Google cloud platform and
then at the end we'll take questions so
if you have any questions feel free to
jot them down we have a microphone and I
will be moderating that discussion so
from there I mean to bring up Arun to
tell us about what they're doing at
Stanford there you are
[Applause]
Keith's cloud engineer at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business
let's dig right in let's talk about
disaster recovery I'd like you to look
at this picture it's a beautiful picture
of San Francisco is that on okay and the
very famous Golden Gate Bridge peeking
out
San Francisco is truly a beautiful city
and I hope in the last few days you've
been able to take a few minutes to look
around enjoy the sights and scenes but
San Francisco is known for one other
thing that's earthquakes we who live
here know about these natural natural
disasters very well this entire area is
situated on six major fault lines and a
slew of smaller ones in fact geologists
predict that in the next 25 years
there's at least a 70% chance of a
significant quake hitting on one of
these faults could happen tomorrow could
happen next year you don't know but what
you but what we do know is the damage
that earthquakes can do back in 1989 we
had a 6.9 earthquake that hit San
Francisco the whole area it was dubbed
the world series earthquake because it
happened just moments before Game three
of the World Series in 1989 that was
between the San Francisco Giants and the
Oakland A's the San Francisco Giants and
the Oakland A's just across the bay and
you can see what damage it did a big
gaping hole in the Bay Bridge a downed
building in one San Francisco
neighborhood both of these were just
moments away from where we're sitting
right now
so let's bring this back around if you
as an IT professional or responsible for
your critical data for your organization
and you happen to live in an earthquake
prone area or any place that has
disasters you want to make sure that
that data is safe
this morning I'd like to take you
through our journey of creating a
disaster recovery plan in doing so I'll
talk about three major topics why we
chose the cloud why we chose Google and
how we achieved disaster recovery with
zero downtime
the Graduate School of Business at
Stanford has over 200 terabytes of
critical research data this data is
sitting on our Nass on-premise on
storage disk from a major storage vendor
our faculty researchers use this data as
use this data to create and publish
major papers on topics from anywhere
from International Economics to human
behavior
this research is world-renowned and it's
critical to attracting top talent to the
to the university both faculty and
students amazingly as of just two years
ago this data was not even backed up
clearly we needed a disaster recovery
plan and we needed one implemented very
quickly as we talked about it many
requirements came to mind we wanted to
make sure that our disaster recovery
plan was geo diverse as I've just been
talking about we didn't want an
earthquake to hit a data center and take
out our NASA and RDR solution all at
once
our solution had to be highly available
our solution had to be scalable as our
data footprint grew we wanted the
solution to grow with it without any
major we architecture and we need any
quick reto recovery times in the event
of a disaster as we did our basic
research it was clear and we were
appointed very quickly to using the
cloud it was the most efficient the most
cost effective way of achieving of
achieving these various goals add to
that
the facts that the university had
recently printed it's cloud vision
statement in it it stated that the
university wanted to move the majority
of its IT infrastructure out to the
cloud by 2019
that's just next year but that confirmed
the direction that we were going I'll
let you read Stanford's cloud vision
statement which is up here on the screen
and it will again point out the keywords
cost efficiency scalability and
accessibility cost of course as a major
there's a big factor on any major
initiative especially when you're
dealing with university budgets in our
case when we started thinking about
disaster recovery we thought hey why not
just bring in another Nass
bring it on premise copy all the bits
from our production ass to the second
ass and thereby we would have our
solution we talked to our storage vendor
and they sent us a quote the quote came
in at a hundred and thirty seven
thousand dollars not chump change Fry's
further that didn't include the
installation costs nor did it include
the system administration cost that we
would need to bear over the lifetime of
this new solution Google Cloud Storage
by comparison
had minimal upfront costs and it billed
monthly depending of course on the size
of your data footprint
we estimated that in the first year that
would come out to around $60,000 for us
you can see the big price difference
beyond cost there were many other
reasons as to why we chose Google our
university had already a pre-existing
business agreement with Google and in
that agreement we could store high-risk
data out into GCS and even Pho data that
was important to us
second we had a fantastic team assigned
to us from Google once they learned
about our project they worked hard to
find the right solution for our dr they
communicated with us continuously and as
a matter of fact we met at this very
same conference a year ago i was able to
sit down to sit down with him talk about
our needs talk about our requirements
they took lots of notes that went back
they figured out some possible solutions
and they came back quickly
once we talked about it we discovered
that there was a particular google
partner that would potentially serve our
purpose very well i'd like to go into a
little bit of detail about that
particular partner that was a company
called comprise comprises a company and
a software that allows you to analyze
move and manage your data across all
your disk volumes and in fact across
object stores out in the cloud
together with GCS the comprise software
provided for as a complete dr solution
and one that we have in place today the
company itself was wonderful to work
with
they developed a collaborative
relationship with us they were eager to
hear our feedback we were eager to give
them our feedback and in fact much of
that was introduced into future versions
of their software that's all fine and
good but what really sold as
uncompromised was the capabilities of
their software from this picture I hope
you can see that we were able to
replicate all 200 terabytes of our
research data out to GCS moreover and
this is important the files came over
while preserving all file attributes
more specifically it preserved all
security file attributes and even more
specifically it preserved nfsv4
security file attributes we came to
learn that NS nfsv4 is not highly
supported but it was critical to our
solution once all of our data was out at
GCS the comprised software then allowed
us to actually mount that Google GCS
bucket back to our on-prem compute
hardware I hope you can see then that if
our NASA ever went out we could simply
mount the GCS bucket and we would be up
and running with our with our data with
zero downtime as they say that's exactly
what the doctor ordered in conclusion
then I want to state again how important
it was for us to achieve disaster
recovery we did it with GCS and with
comp rise and together we they formed a
solid solution that again is in place
for us today
looking ahead now that all of our data
is safely out into the cloud we could
imagine
hey maybe instead of having our on
premise data may be our primary store
should be out in the cloud and if we did
that we could then take the next step
and think about hey maybe we should put
our compute out in the out in the cloud
and it's in essence we would have Google
- all of the infrastructure heavy
lifting for us and we could concentrate
on what value-add we're there for namely
the data data analysis data integration
and that sort of thing putting all of
that compute out into the cloud also
minimizes our on-prem footprint which is
a very good thing no servers no
administration no headaches and when you
live here in the earthquake prone
country as I was talking about you don't
want to mess around with losing your
data and your compute thanks very much
gonna hand it over to Steven
Thank You Arun hi everyone my name is
Steven and I'm with the University of
Minnesota I'm the service owner for
collaboration and web content services
the university Minnesota comprised of
five main campuses across the state of
Minnesota
the Twin Cities being the largest we
have about a hundred thousand students
and approximately 35,000 faculty and
staff my role here is to ensure that the
service is delivered through operations
process improvement and through
strategic direction in the collaboration
web content space what I want to talk
about next is the University of
Minnesota and how we have 200 million
files and 2.3 petabytes in the cloud
we're ready for storms tornadoes and
even the occasional squirrel and I'll
explain that one later well we don't
have earthquakes like Arun did we have
other things that caused us to think
about dr and so i want to walk you
through how we've done it here at the
university and how you can do the same
the university has been an early adopter
of google since 2009 but we didn't all
jump right in as I look back to those
days in the late 2000s we were
contemplating about moving to Google as
a collaboration platform we had pockets
of users using Google and wanting
leadership and others to move into this
direction but the rest of the campus
didn't have an appetite for it
faculty we're concerned about storage
how they access their files where they
find it administration were concerned
about security performance and uptime
but all in all the questions really boil
down to two things one can we trust
Google and two well Google be reliable
so through a series of town halls with
stakeholders and with leadership we
concluded that the benefits in the cloud
just far outweighed those concerns for
example we used use word docs you know
how you create them you send them off
someone would download them make changes
send them right back since we moved to
Google Docs the experience for our users
has been just tremendous
we now have an any
time anywhere and any device real-time
collaboration we also wanted to strive
after a high availability infrastructure
so we asked ourselves how as an
institution how do we minimize the
downtime that students staff and faculty
have in using these products and so we
were after high availability to the five
nines and I think we pretty much achieve
that with Google but the largest benefit
however is in the savings and that's
what I want to talk about next the
savings we achieve from going to Google
were in time and money we used to spend
a lot of time managing servers patching
them monitoring them troubleshooting
them you know how that works and usually
we get a vendor patch then and we
applied them and we think that they
tested it thoroughly they didn't we
applied them course disruption in
disaster right well since moving our
files to Google you know we don't have
to worry about that anymore Google does
a better job of it than we can so why
not let them manage it so our sysadmin
is now really are focusing on other
priorities where their expertise is
needed in that area the other benefit
that we mentioned where other the
savings in terms of money we asked
Gartner to come in and do an independent
analysis of what the savings would be
the university moved to an all cloud
platform collaboration platform versus
building something on Prem they
determined that the university would
save approximately fifteen million
dollars for those in higher education
you know that's not a small number in
and it's always a decreasing budget
every year right so we're asked to do
more with less and so my question to you
is what could you do with 15 million
dollars in that savings well what we did
was we went to administration I went to
faculty and we said to them here's
something you don't hear every day
here's 15 million dollars for you what
do you wanna do with it they came back
and they said we want this a
collaborative teaching and learning
classroom this is where the university
invested the savings
this area this building here houses ten
of the high-tech active learning
classrooms that we have on campus for
those who aren't familiar with what
active learning classrooms are they are
classroom designed to offer a flexible
environment that encourages group work
class participation and increased
participation students here are working
on projects together they're
collaborating sharing the results within
each other in the classroom through
technologies implemented in that
building this facility is also a big
draw on campus not only for teaching
learning but for also other events that
need a collaborative learning space
Stephen can recall that he was here at
this same place in March for our Google
day event using the facilities and the
equipment in this room but these
students however have an ever increasing
expectation of availability and
reliability on the enterprise
applications that we have in our data
center and so I want to take a look at
two examples of where the impact of
those data centers are caused a dr
situation the picture on your left shows
you a large body of Minnesota water on
the picture on your right shows you one
of the university's data center imagine
all this water flooding into that data
center when that happened obviously our
files and servers were unavailable and
our users were very upset and they
didn't want this to happen again
so we thought about how we would
mitigate this and so we said we needed
to have a cloud file storage solution
that would allow the users to continue
to access their files and store them
without having to worry about a flood
because moving the data center was not
an option and so what we wanted to do
was we looked and moved to the files
that we had to Google Drive and so our
last our most recent flood wasn't as
severe as the first one
but when it happened we were already in
the cloud and we were unaffected by that
from a user standpoint my next dr
example could when we had an important
upgrade that we went live with
we had a complex year-long project to
upgrade a key business application and
we the upgrade was complete and we're
ready for the launch on the day of the
launch one of the Transformers powering
our data center blew up and caught fire
and obviously this delayed our launch
anybody care to guess what caused that
transform or double to catch fire yeah
good you guys are paying attention
that's right so hard to believe but a
squirrel somehow found its way into the
transformer build its nest or whatever
and caught fire caused the fire to take
down our data center yeah
this caused IT to have a huge black eye
so all credibility and trust with IT
went out the window that day it took us
a long time to rebuild that relationship
and earn their trust again in our
partnership with them you can plan for
it anything that's on you can't really
plan for anything that's unexpected
right and here are two examples of that
I can share more of just some of these
crazy stories but you just can't plan
for but by leveraging Google what we did
was we took all of our files that
everybody was using and put them in the
cloud to prepare and plan for these
uneventful or unplanned events that
happened like like our users this girl
here was just looking for a safe place
to store it's nuts right so isn't that
what we're here to learn about how we
can securely store our files now that we
talked a little about the ER I want to
switch gears and just talk about team
drives imagine a scenario scenario with
me for a second you have a staff person
who's been with your place for seven
years creating content and so on they're
ready to move on now and now it's time
for them to to to go how does an
organization effectively off-board that
person while retaining these documents
and make sure that they don't leave with
that person how does the organization do
that right now well
prior to team drives whenever a staff
person left they had this daunting task
ahead of them which they don't want to
do and that is that their teams needed
them to change ownership of all the
working documents that they had and
assign that to a new person and this was
a process that was very haphazard it was
painful for the business staff person
who was departing really didn't want to
do this I'm gone one week laughs I'm not
gonna sit here and spend hours trying to
change ownership of documents and so it
was we usually have to contact that
person after when they left and ask them
to reassign these documents to another
person what team drives improves this
for us and it allows the team to own the
documents versus an individual and so
team drives helps us have a better
off-boarding experience and allows us to
improve that process in a more effective
way so that the documents stay with the
organization so in conclusion you can
see how we've been at the university
focused on security performance
availability real-time collaboration and
with team environments the savings we
gain from moving to Google allowed us to
reinvest those funds into areas where
the student learning experience has made
the University one of the top places to
attend and going forward we want to be
able to look at moving to an all cloud
file storage solution were applicable
and continue the momentum or moving
these files we have to the cloud we want
to continue to develop team drives in an
environment for colleges and business
units to put their files in and have a
better off-boarding experience as you
can see we have 200 million files and
we're just getting started
thank you and I'll hand it over to Josh
[Applause]
good morning everyone my name is Josh
Humphrey from Georgia State University
in Atlanta Georgia and this morning I'm
going to share with you how Georgia
State has moved into the cloud and how
that move has greatly improved our
overall disaster recovery planning our
main priority was how could we better
protect the university's data without
breaking the bank in the process so many
of you may remember a small storm that
happened last year hurricane Irma and
the destruction that it caused Atlanta
which normally does not receive storms
of this caliber was in the projected
path as it was entering the u.s. so
since this was our first major storm
that we were going to face luckily we
had already started moving our backup
data into Google Nearline storage we
knew this storm was going to put GCP to
the test and we felt very confident that
we're gonna be able to access our data
in case you know the worst were to
happen so knowing this information we
were able to not worry about how secure
and how safe our files were the whole
team could then focus on more pressing
issues as we prepare prepared for the
storm to hit luckily at the last moment
the storm weakened and actually changed
course so we did not have any major
outages but it did help us prepare for
you know any future ones that may come
down the road so our initial move to the
cloud was very small we took very small
baby steps
we had a initiative several years back
that was wanting us to move some of our
workloads into the cloud so we decided
to not focus on major applications and
systems and today we decided to keep it
simple and we targeted our 100-plus
terabytes of our backup data reason we
targeted this was we were the ownership
of the backup data so we didn't have to
deal with other half application teams
and we wouldn't have to you know open up
a lot of extra security rules and stuff
working with those teams we could do it
all in-house mm-hmm so knowing that our
backup application actually supported
multiple connections to clouds we chose
Google near line and we decided to start
a pilot so within a couple of days of
deciding we were going to do this pilot
we created our GCP accounts we then
created our storage buckets within near
line and we connected our backup
application into the storage buckets the
next step was we created a new storage
policy and we've dumped the couple of
our dev systems into that storage policy
to have that data start shipping off to
Nearline so for about two months we let
that system run while we learned you
know how to manage this data what was
the process of adding new systems what
was the process of restoring so on and
so forth so two of the main questions
that we were asking ourselves while we
were doing this two-month pilot was was
cloud going to work for us for our
recovery planning for our backup data
and was Google going to be the best
option for hosting this so after the
two-month time frame we found out how
easy it was to add more systems into
Nearline found out how easy it was to
restore these systems both at a file
level and a full server level and so I
had about eight months we were good we
decided to go all-in and push all of our
backup data into Google Nearline so now
that we were all in it was time to cut
also our security blanket aside and
doing this saved us a lot of time and
money and let me explain so before prior
to getting rid of our security blanket
we were using tapes as our d'art plan so
everyday tapes backup data would be
copied to tape so we had a dedicated
team at our data center who would go in
or take the tapes we had a third-party
company come in pick up the tapes send
them off to a secure remote site if we
ever needed to
restore anything we would contact that
company hoping that would have requested
the correct tapes they would bring them
back in we'd load them in our tape
library and all that to just start doing
their restore so we decided it was now
time we were we felt confident and
Google and the ability to restore this
data in case we needed it so we
decommissioned that tape library and
became 100% dependent on GCP in case of
disaster or any other type of emergency
so now that we no longer had to take
library we no longer had the other
hardware costs associated and the other
third-party support we saw an average
savings yearly savings of around 44% and
we've been using GCP for almost three
years now and we've seen this about the
same time amount every year so as Steve
said an education that is a huge amount
when you're dealing with budgets that
you know aren't constant year-to-year
and because this is such a significant
number we often use this and whenever
people ask us you know why did you move
to the cloud and we just bring the sums
and this is this is our savings so this
is it's one of the big reasons we move
usability and the savings I saw from the
call savings we also were able to
reallocate about ten of our data center
workers into other areas of the IT
department where their skill sets could
be better used so instead of working on
swapping out the tapes and everything
those individuals because then could
then go work in either our help desk
some of them went into our server admin
team and someone went into our
networking admin team so it was a better
use of their time better used of
University's time and money having them
moved out and into the other areas of
the university so now that we were all
in with GCP with using an airline we
were now able to reap some of the
benefits of using cloud services three
of those being location accessing growth
so being in Georgia
we have a 30-mile requirement for D our
site Google's data centers are far
beyond Georgia's boundaries so we
immediately gain that that ability of or
then checkmark of is your data outside
of a certain time of mileage radius in
case there was a disaster recovery we
also have the ability to simple
configuration change and we can then
have that data replicated to one of many
other data centers within the country we
also have near instant access to hard
data like I mentioned before with tapes
we had to contact the content or the
tape library company have them ship the
tapes back to us before we could even
start that restore now there are backup
application a couple of clicks and we're
started streaming our backups back to
our data center almost nearly instantly
and we also have the ability to grow and
expand our retention rates for our
backups without the cost of extra
hardware without the cost of the extra
cooling in our data centers and the
electricity that comes with that so now
within our backup application one
configuration change and we've expanded
our overall retention rate we can add
days weeks months even make it
indefinite and it only costs us the the
monthly storage bill from Google so
since we're utilizing Nearline we
recognize that we're still only
scratching the surface of the services
that Google and using cloud technologies
provides us so one of the main things
that we're looking for in the future is
how can we get to the point where we can
utilize a lot more of the services that
Google provides and hopefully with the
ability to one day just flip the switch
and have all of our mission critical
systems come online you know near
instantly within GCP so we can continue
running our data center as seamlessly as
possible and then see what other
integrations we might be able to utilize
from that Google Offers
so in conclusion my advice to any of you
on the audience who was looking to
either start your journey into using
cloud technologies or if you want to
expand on your current environment is
very much is to just keep it simple and
start with the small things since we had
a initiative and we decided to not focus
on large applications we just took small
chunks of things that we knew we could
get those easy wins with that's kind of
the biggest advice I could give to
anybody is you know we all probably have
a big picture of what we would like to
get to in the long run but find those
little pieces of that picture try to get
successful in those and then as you you
know work on those little pieces
the success rate keeps going up and up
and then eventually you've had your
you've covered the whole picture that
you were looking to do and thank you
[Applause]
[Music]